hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga and we are starting the
match Paul Morphy versus Thomas Wilson
Barnes after his match with Simon
Standish Bowden morphine out takes the
legendary mr. takes on the legendary mr.
Barnes and you will see that mr. Barnes
the gameplay is well peculiar to say the
least
so without further ado let's check out
the game this is only one of the games
we're going to show all in all they
played a total of 26 games but not all
26 exist in recorded format so we are
only going to show some so Morphy with
the white pieces now opens with E 4 with
E 5 by mr. Barnes but and Bishop the c-4
going for bishops opening we have Knight
f6 and now Knight to f3 we transpose
into the petrov defense with morphia
omitting the e4 pawn by basically just
playing Bishop to c4
so mr. barn accepts the pawn we have
Knight captures and now Knight to c3
again but that was very well known in
those days even even Bowden was a big
fan of it we have Knight captures D
captures and now f6 strengthening the e5
pawn and although yes you played f6 very
early on in the game however you will
have some nice support for the 5 and
then you will have this massive center
here so it's not bad
morphic castles and now Knight to c6 you
still cannot go for d5 as both the
bishop and the queen guard dad so here
Knights the h4 Morphy goes for DF v
square as for the moment the knight is
able to reach it the bishop still
doesn't cover it and while you could
play something like d5 with a pawn
sacrifice maybe you can play d6 for the
bishop to guard the square mr. Barnes
actually plays Queen to e7 and he
invites more feet to go Knight to f5 to
f5 and it is ever moved as a move 7th at
this position has never been reached
again and now Murphy goes for Knight to
f5 so the Queen is under attack
Queen to c5 now putting pressure on the
brush of Murphy moves the Bishop and
only now d5 saying that now you cannot
capture on d5 since your knight is
hanging on f5 that's why mr. Barnes
invited more fizz Knight to f5 so Murphy
just continues development with Bishop
to e3
with an attack on the Queen so we don't
have time to grab the night Queen to a5
by Barnes and now now you can see that
although morphe did try to go for some
rapid development mr. Barnes isn't doing
all that bad as he has a massive Center
here he has a knight in the game a queen
into the game
the knight is under attack so it's very
hard to decide like you could go for
some Knight characters and g7 action
here followed by Queen h5 check and then
f4 to try and bust open the position but
it's hard to say if this is a enough
compensation for the sacrifice piece so
morphe decides to go back with Knight to
h4 instead and now Bishop to e6 Barnes
just keeps on developing adds another
defender to the d5 pawn and only now
Queen to h5 check by Murphy and here
Barnes goes for g6 he invites the knight
in and the Morphy goes for it Knight
characters in g6 now you cannot capture
because of captures so Barnes just pins
the night and now you cannot capture
because of characters here and morphic
goes Queen to h4 saying ok I will give
you a knight but I will capture on f6
and Byrne says ok no problem we have
captures captures the rook is now under
attack so rook g8 by mr. Barnes and rook
8d one more feet more feet just calmly
it continues the game like hidden just
sacrificed material and Bishop the east
sub kicking the Queen away we have Queen
that is 6 pinning the bishop now also
with a double attack triple attack here
on the pawn and Bishop the f7 attacking
and defending undie 5 so more he has to
move the Queen and he was for Queen to
h3 and it's like the only good square to
go to you do not want to allow queenside
castle if you lock means that castle
then black is just better black is still
better but with queenside castle if the
King leaves the center of the board it's
just light a light soft 4 for Murphy and
here of course Barnes knows this and he
wants the castle however he needs to
somehow block this diagonal so he goes
for Knights to d8 and it's a bit too
optimistic he wants to get either the
denied or the Bishop to e6 to block the
Queen and h3 and then just Castle
queenside or obviously the night as the
knight is not blocking the path however
Murphy now goes for f4 and things things
start
now if you try something like knife to
e6 to try and do that just a rook
captures and e5 will be extremely strong
and now the Queen is under attack the e5
pawn is under attack and you just give
back a bit too much so here on f5 and f4
Barnes played efore he said okay we're
not doing that and well our Bishop still
needs to be guarding the d5 pawn but now
we have another interesting move here
but even pause the pause the video here
and try to find this interesting move
more if you played while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on deciding that it's time to part with
the rook and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's rook
captures on d5 now the queen is under
attack and also Queen to d7 is coming so
you do have to capture the route which
is what Morphy mr. Barnes did with
Bishop captures on d5 but now Queen h5
check and now everything nicely connects
here on d5 so King f8 and here just
bishop character son d5 with an attack
on the rook here so you don't have to
worry about checkmate the knight
fortunately covers BDF 7 squares so it's
not a problem so rook g7 and now the
move you had to see to sacrifice the
rook b4 nicely kicking the Queen away we
have Queen to a6 and now even f5 and now
again there's a well just what do you do
if f6 comes you don't you really don't
want to open up this file so what mr.
Barnes did here is that he decided okay
we're not gonna block the pawn with the
Queen that's I mean the Queen is much
too valuable to waste on blocking upon
so we're just gonna play nice to f7 and
we will play perhaps Queen f6 on the
next move now we can bring the rook into
the game as well however this loses the
game for Barnes but you will pause the
video and figure out why well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations on paying attention as
we already mentioned that the opening of
the F file wins however it's not as
straight forward as it seems
give me just just give me a second aha
but luckily it's not the mailman it's
Jelena so here you of course go f6 and
now it seems like yeah of course you're
just giving up a pawn but not really
because you had to find the star move so
of course if you don't want to lose the
piece Bishop captures on f6 but now
comes b5 and now you can see that you
don't have all that many squares
available to your Queen if you move the
Queen you just lose on f6 and if you
don't well this is covered by the bishop
this is this covered by the bishops only
these six remains and this is what mr.
Barnes goes for he puts with the Queen
on d6 but now comes Bishop captures on
f7 and you cannot recapture because if
you recapture you've also set up a trick
here the Queen and Bishop guard the c5
square so if you capture then Bishop c5
just wins the Queen that's more his idea
so Barnes has to play b6 to restrict
this the movement of the bishop but now
comes Bishop to h6 and now everything is
completely pinned I thought it was a a
nice quote to use for this game the pin
is mightier than the sword as you know
it's just the pins for the entire game
so this is now cannot be captured and
there's not much you can do here King e7
is played but now just Bishop captures
and g7 Bishop captures and Bishop back
to b3 and although morphe is now
regarding material up only one pawn
there is not much to be done
rook and queen can now come to 7 which
will be deadly so mr. Barnes played rook
to f8 but it's not not much
rook captures on f8 with sorry first
rook to f7 check not captures now you
will have to capture here is where
Barnes captured and now Queen captures
on f7 now the bishop falls as well
King to d8 and now Queen captures Bishop
on g7 and the barn still has this nice
efore past pawn going for him so he will
try to make use of that Queen d1 check
King f2 Queen d2 chair but now King g3
and now he starts pushing the passed
pawn but it is
it is not enough Queen f6 check by
morphic King to see it and now Bishop to
e6 width check we have king to b7 and
here more features played Queen to f3
check and it was in this position that
Thomas Wilson Barnes resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
since it's a mate in three and that's
that's just it
so here your is he resigned as now you
can move the King but if you move the
King you're just getting checkmate at
queen of fate check you're gonna go to
b7 and now it's just Queen to see it
checkmate not not a lot of fun but yeah
Barnes played this really really nicely
he played f6 he grabbed the center he
pushed more fee all the way back but
then he'd made that one imprecise move
that night to d8 idea
I would simply allowed more feet to make
use of the position here after Queen h3
he went Knights to d8 and it was just
giving Morphy a bit too much time so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank tio crew and
Patrick pagoda at our equal Islam
siddharta Bakke and on 11h for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check through all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Morphy saga we are continuing with
the match with mr. Barnes and we will
see what happens then will the match
with Stanton happen or not what's taking
so long or you know what else could have
happened
however they are checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day